let's see let's go next to the four one
seven area code caller from four one
seven who's there
hi David this is Deon from southwest
Missouri hey Diana what's going on I was
I've been paying attention to this 2020
lead-up and it seems like the Democratic
Party has a favorite it's Kamala Harris
I don't know if you agree with that or
not well I think that works let's
explore it why do you think that well
she got a Town Hall on CNN but the did
he arrange that or was that something
CNN pushed for that's I mean I was
wondering the same thing but I I mean
maybe other candidates have also been
offered town halls I don't know you know
that that is a possibility and if it's
not the DNC and it is just a CNN there
there is some sort of contingent that
does obviously back her I agree I agree
but as far as the Town Hall I think that
if the DNC went to CNN and said hey I
know we have eight people running but we
just want you to do a common law Kamala
Harris town hall and no no others some
part of me feels like after what
happened in 2016 it would have leaked
that the DNC has already sort of like
crowned her so I don't know I'm not
telling I'm not saying you're wrong I'm
just saying I don't know that the Town
Hall is the evidence for it sure but
that's actually not my question
my question is if if she is the the
frontrunner and she does get pushed
forward and you know she does have the
momentum is she a wolf in sheep's
clothing
I I don't know if I believe any of the
things she says based on her record as a
prosecutor who has some questionable
practices in the past and I've brought
this up I've brought this up I also am
unsure when it comes to the criminal
justice record and when it comes to you
know I hate I'm but this is this I knew
this was going to happen and it's
starting to happen
the medicare-for-all thing I don't know
if you've been following any of the
stuff we've been saying about
this about this issue Dion but I've been
saying that medicare-for-all is sort of
becoming a litmus test for Democrats for
2020 but it's becoming a litmus test and
in name only where you are going to see
I would guess just about every candidate
say oh yeah I believe medicare-for-all
or something like it is what we should
get to but then kind of back off of it
and say but here are some ways we can
just tweak the system we have sort of
thing she's already starting to do that
and that is definitely another concern
to me absolutely I appreciate you taking
the call that's all I really had to ask
about okay great Dion great to hear from
you appreciate you calling in